et vous jacques que vous avez aussi des
recettes de cuisine dont la lame et vous
n'avez pas l'air très content
aujourd'hui c'est curieux tout à l'heure
j'étais la poule au pot d'henri iv
maintenant les recettes de franchise
galloise sur une chose pour les poules
alors les poules c'est uniquement bon
avec manger quand il ya là une injustice
scandaleuse mais c'est vrai qu'on doit d
un bon chien ça veut dire en gros chien
un bon chat agence tisha une bonne poule
on parle de la retire ou de la bouillie
à supposer que je dise que ce magic est
une bonne jeune femme et que ça veut
dire ça y est pas coté n'a pas vraiment
non voilà pourquoi le scandale c'est
pourquoi il faut réhabiliter les poules
nous disons qu'elles sont bêtes et ce
n'est pas vrai je vais le démontrer
d'abord ne sortent elles la cool
il se trouve que le grand-père des de
toutes nos poules tous nos coqs vite
encore prévu cet animal formidable
d'argent décor jallet un coq ou comme ça
noir avec un grand camail rouge une
belle que tout en or superbe n'est ce
pas on appelle le coq de banques y va
mais quand on rencontre on s'écarte 1 il
vit dans sa forêt là-bas banques y va où
il y eut encore il ya 6000 ans quand ils
ont commencé à peupler l'asie à ce
moment là il est probable qu'ils
assimilent ans les asiatiques ont
commencé à apprivoiser des coques des
pool de banques y va puis que petit à
petit tribu la tribu ça a gagné il ya
3000 ans à peu près il y avait déjà des
poules et des coqs petit-fils de ce
magnifique coque de banques y va ce
phénomène et qui picorer dans les cours
de ferme la recette c'est là que je vais
vous parlez pas c'est celle là serait
intéressante et par les malheureuses
poule de batterie vous savez ces poulets
industriels qu'on abrutis qui l'ont
d'ailleurs de nuit diot et dont la chair
et y mangera pas nos poules qu'on dit
bête sont les premiers animaux chez ti
les hommes ont découvert une
organisation sociale parfaitement il ya
une trentaine d'années on l'a découvert
ça chaque poule est capable de
reconnaître 27 autres poules
plus qu'un bébé d'un an si on vous
disait quand bébé d'un an est moins
intelligent d'une poule bon eh non
seulement elle les reconnaît
mais les classes parce qu'il ya une
hiérarchie parmi les poules en là ça
devient un peu choquant il ya des poules
de premier rang de deuxième ronde
troisième en bas et les poules de rang
supérieur a le droit de donner des coups
de bec
c'est ce qu'on appelle le droit de
piquage donné les coups de bec à l'autre
sans que l'autre puisse les lire on est
bas et de manger avant tel camp par
exemple une poule le troisième rang
un grain par terre comme ça elle craque
matière et trouve un grain elle regarde
d'abord à droite et à gauche
si la personne c'est les seuls éléments
jra son grain mais s'il ya une poule
d'un rang supérieur à elle elle lui
laissera oui c'est un peu injuste
les amis des poules vous diront que ça
évite les disputera quand même c'est un
petit peu injuste
lorsqu'il ya là c'est curieux c'est dire
une poule au milieu de tout ça qui a une
priorité absolue et passe au premier
rang c'est la mère poule suivie de ses
poussins c'était comme c'est joli un
gros souvenir poule avec les prochains
et ses petits pouces a toujours une qui
la suivent alors celle là il a le droit
de manger avant tout le monde de donner
des coups de bec à tout le monde
pourquoi pas simplement parce qu'il ya
deux choses à faire que sur très
important d'abord défendre ses petits
pilous vous savez la mère poule pas
costaud une poule mais si elle rencontre
un chien aussi un chat qui approche
auprès de ces petits bijoux et fonce
dessus et l'autre soit pas parce qu'elle
très courageux il confié plus bon et
puis elle leur apprend à vivre parce que
les petits poussins ne savent pas par
terre reconnaître ce qui est bon à
manger série tigres n alors on voit ce
geste très jolie la mère poule qui
écarte avec ses pattes
actuellement cinq hot press particuliers
et les poussins arrive c'est qu'elle a
trouvé quelque chose de très bien alors
bon on a trouvé cette sécheresse viral
sur la priorité de la mère poule
on l'a découvert aussi que certaines
poules quand on les sort
par exemple vous avez une poule du
premier rang pour une première catégorie
qui passe à voir tout le monde qui donne
des coups de bec à tout le monde vous la
sortie de la banque pendant huit jours
vous la ramenez elle passe au dernier
rang il faudra qu'elle se bat avec les
autres pour revenir reprendre sa place
c'est extrêmement curieux yaojie naïsso
grassi parmi les poules c'est que par
exemple les poules de la race les gones
sont très très belles poules qui sont
aux noirs avec du rouge sont toujours
dominante par rapport aux autres
alors on s'est demandé comment ces six
rondes cette aristocratie cette
hiérarchie était né parmi les poules et
on a fini à 2 par découvrir que les
textiles et poussait était tout petit
oui les petits pilous quand ils sont
sortis le lot d'erreurs
ils sont là suivent la mère poule dans
un peu bête ils comprennent rien puis au
bout de huit jours
il commence à prendre chacun leur
personnalité et à ce moment là il se bat
et il se bat 2 à 2
on est alors à franck une trempe b toute
sa vie il sera supérieur de bec sur les
petites routes d'altitude et rom de
kipushi c'est pas grave mais cessera
toute sa vie supérieure à b et c b a
battu c b sera supérieur à c'est toute
sa vie
ce moyen de ces dernières courbes et
lyon
c'est qu'il arrive suivez moi bien que
le poussin à battre le poussins b il ne
dominera b bat c il ne dominera messi
sebaâ à son tour ça peut arriver il a
été en famille là bas tu as alors vous
avez à 2 min b qui domine c'est qu'ils
dominent à il aura ce moment là si vous
voulez faire une sale blague à vos
poules vous prenez vos trois poules vous
mettiez de bretelles d'assiettes de
graines alors à arrive dans l'assiette
de graines bouscule paix puisqu'il
domine wee b arrive il bouscule ses
puisque il le domine
oui mais c'est lui qui domina alors ils
bousculent à qui bouscule b qui bouscule
ses qui bouscule acquise et vos trois
poules tourneront en rond autour de leur
assiette au monde qui commencera à
manger la première et enfin toujours
pour bien établir que les poules sont
pas aussi soit qu'on le dit les poules
savent prévoir le temps beaucoup mieux
que nous quand il pleut à la campagne
bon si vous voyez les poules courir
s'abriter c'est que la pluie ne durera
pas et oui parce que ceux proposant se
mouiller puisque leur s arrêter bientôt
alors elle s'abrite mais si vous les
voyez rester c'est que la pluie va durer
c'est le régal de se mouiller alors vous
comprenez pas tout de même un animal qui
a une organisation sociale qui défend la
mère de famille qui a toute une
hiérarchie qui adhérent qui sait prévoir
le temps et ils ont dit que c'est bête
c'est un scandale voilà exactement ce
que je voulais dire il faut réhabiliter
les poules merci jacques en tout cas
c'est vrai leçon avec ce que vous avez
dit je constate qu'elles sont non
seulement astucieuse mais qu'elles ont
plein de savoir vivant plus très bien
merci zac